your next game on the way where this is
finish guy with lots of eyes in the name
Kings in young I go for the h3 variation
unless he's no is playing something else
yeah this is a little-known sideline but
it's actually pretty easy way for for y2
to play this kind of position also have
cost got the advantage of avoiding lots
of them for Theoretical lines it's a
strange move I think it just needs to
get get back now I think he just sorry
it just don't can't allow me to take and
then I got you should see for which is
not a huge problem but I want to post
the bishop there anyway okay he lets me
take it too surprising okay
so what now of course I want to flip the
ship c4 at some point it's not not
possible at the moment night a4ai Queen
a fourth it looks very artificial I
think
maybe just just a normal move with the
Queen and maybe it also supports Bishop
c4 later rook t8 yeah it's just that's
just develop normally on create the
looking idea for black Harris rook to d4
it's not entirely impossible if he's an
adventurous mutti he could have tried
that
yeah i think this position should be
about equal maybe slightly better for
white due to the two bishops and the
slide Spader's base advantage but still
black is very solid you can for instance
go nite f-86 year is doing this right
now and i think i need to play the
Bishop to c4 in order to to simply
exchange here the they wants to go to a
forum interesting question would be what
about queen bee three at this position
or just exchange on the rocks yeah let's
count can't be bad really in the end
game i think i would really have a
slight advantage i got the better bishop
only three and still some ideas on the
queenside
of course the idea of this maneuver
wasn't too to give checkmate but to go
to d3
I could to create now force him back
maybe
I also really like the idea of g3 let
him take on 83 King g2 and then try to
to catch this night on age 3 would also
surround queen d 8 so he would it would
need to take care of both things
it's interesting it's an interesting
idea
check
maybe even to age too because Queen f1
could be an idea to to catch the catch
tonight I hope this isn't entirely
ridiculous ok quindi aid is now the idea
ok and now he's also got a square G 5k
this simply didn't work
we should have seen this move okay maybe
queen d6 trying to get something quick
with a deep on if it takes this journey
to look after the slide
yeah this is a winning position for
black thing
TM white resides so g3 was indeed
ridiculous especially considering that
with some normal moves I would just have
a fine position I Queen d8 something
hard to imagine that wife could lose
such a position yeah but I didn't attend
really i didn't really see him Bishop of
six which is not not difficult I must
admit yeah it stupid stupid loss
actually